in this video we'll study the decoder
architecture
an example of a popular decoder only
architecture is gpt2
in order to understand how decoders work
we recommend taking a look at the video
regarding encoders
they're extremely similar to decoders
one can use a decoder for most of the
same tasks as an encoder
albeit with generally a little loss of
performance
let's take the same approach we have
taken with the encoder to try and
understand the architectural differences
between an encoder and a decoder
we'll use a small example using three
words we pass them
through their decoder we retrieve a
numerical representation
for each word here for example
the decoder converts the three words
welcome to nyc
in these three sequences of numbers the
decoder outputs exactly one sequence of
numbers
per input word this numerical
representation
can also be called a feature vector or a
feature tensor
let's dive in this representation it
contains one vector per word that was
passed
through the decoder each of these
vectors is a numerical representation of
the word in question
the dimension of that vector is defined
by the architecture of the model
where the decoder differs from the
encoder is principally with its
self-attention mechanism it's using what
is called masked self-attention
here for example if we focus on the word
two we'll see that his vector is
absolutely unmodified by the nyc word
that's because all the words on the
right also known as the right context of
the word
is masked rather than benefiting from
all the words on the left
and right so the bi-directional context
decoders only have access to a single
context
which can be the left context or the
right context
the masked self-attention mechanism
differs from the self-attention
mechanism
by using an additional mask to hide the
context on either side of the word
the words numerical representation will
not be affected by the words in the
hidden context
so when should one use ad code decoders
like encoders
can be used as standalone models as they
generate a numerical representation
they can also be used in a wide variety
of tasks
however the strength of a decoder lies
in the way a word can only have access
to its left context
having only access to their left context
they're inherently good at text
generation
the ability to generate a word or a
sequence of words
given a known sequence of words this is
known as causal language modeling
or natural language generation
here's an example of how causal language
modeling works
we start with an initial word which is
my
we use this as input for the decoder
the model outputs a vector of numbers
and this vector contains information
about the sequence which is here a
single word
we apply a small transformation to that
vector so that it maps to all the words
known by the model which is a mapping
that we'll see later
called a language modelling head we
identify that the model believes that
the most
probable following word is name
we then take that new word and add it to
the initial sequence
from my we are now at my name this is
where the autoregressive aspect comes in
autoregressive models reuse their past
outputs
as inputs and the following steps
once again we do the exact same
operation
we cast that sequence through the
decoder and retrieve the most probable
following word
in this case it is the word is
we repeat the operation until we're
satisfied
starting from a single word we've now
generated a full sentence
we decide to stop there but we could
continue for a while
gpt2 for example has a maximum context
size of
1024 we could eventually generate up to
a
1024 words and the decoder would still
have some memory of the first words in
the sequence